wenn unser inspiration auch sowie kies
um eine musikerin mit einer ganz ganz
besonderen lebensgeschichte marshall
wurde aufgrund eines geburtsfehlers mit
einem missgebildeten oberschenkelknochen
und verkürzten bein geboren deshalb
musste ihr bein amputiert werden als sie
noch ein kind war verkleidete elz mutter
oft ihre prothese um sie vor blicken
anderer und mobbing zu schützen bis sie
23 war traute sie sich nicht mit kurzen
hosen in die öffentlichkeit mit 24
veröffentlichte er erstmals bikini fotos
und ihr leben änderte sich vollkommen
sie bekamen jede menge positives
feedback und menschen verschiedenster
altersgruppen und schicksale konnten
sich mit ihr identifizieren heute ist
die 27-jährige als sängerin songwriterin
model und motivation sprecherin tätig
sie nutzt ihre erfahrungen um andere
menschen mit unsicherheiten zu ermutigen
und selbstliebe zu verbreiten
unter ihre fotos schreibt die
botschaften wie trag dieses eine kleid
trägt diesen badeanzug warten nicht sein
körper ist perfekt so wie er ist
[Musik]